so
he sat through six hours of cc xp for a
two second godzilla vs con clip
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and i was gonna be doing
a
full breakdown of ccxp but after
watching the event
and being completely disappointed i
thought i'd look into the reasons as to
why this exactly happened
now there are a lot of factors that go
into this such as the event itself
how it was marketed scoopers and you
yes you for causing all your
disappointment
now i'm sure that everyone behind the
event put their heart and soul into it
but for a number of reasons many people
like myself have ended up being
disappointed i'm not having a go at you
i know you tried your best and it sucks
seeing the fan outcry on this one
you guys didn't really do anything wrong
however
what was wrong was how the event was
marketed there was absolutely
no schedule posted in advance and
therefore
many people's imaginations ran wild and
scoopers decided to cash in on that
you know say what they'd heard at the
event even though it wasn't true
now the big announcement that was
apparently going to be at ccxp
was the spider-man 3 teaser trailer
there was several people posting online
that it was gonna be dropped there
officially didn't show up in the panel
and still people were saying well
they're gonna drop it in the middle of
the monster hunter panel
just you wait and see that is a load of
crap and if you know anything about
marketing in general or how
events are run you know you put your big
attraction at the top of the flyer
and then everything below it there was
no way on earth that sony were dropping
a spider-man 3 trailer in the middle of
a monster hunter panel
in fact if sony wanted more people to
watch the monster hunter panel
they would have said up top spider-man 3
is going to be shown at this
make sure you watch the entire thing
instead they said
this is the monster hunter panel that's
it so all the scoopers who said
spider-man 3 was going to be shown there
either they're very very stupid and
don't understand how marketing works
or they think you're stupid and you're
gonna believe them no matter what they
say
so they just put videos out there put
articles out there
and thought well we'll try and make
money whilst no one really knows what's
going on
now a big problem that i have with
scoopers and a reason that i don't do
stuff myself
kind of mention this in the mandalorian
video but i like to try and be as
accurate as possible
i'd rather just do six videos like that
a year get all six right and then people
think
well maybe i can trust this guy a lot of
scoopers have seen
tend to post 50 articles a month get 10
right and say well i got those 10 right
so as you can see
i'm an accurate source they completely
brush to the side everything they got
wrong and just focus on the good which
doesn't really paint out an accurate
picture of them
and i think they know that people have a
very short memory and thus will forgive
them
so what they do is they just milk as
many things as they can
know that people will forget and they
don't really think very highly of their
audience
just my personal opinion but i see it
happening so often
that uh either they're stupid or they
think the audience is
there's no real in-between on it and
unfortunately it's just a way for them
to make money
in my opinion i was superhero nexus this
morning actually said i'm quite a
reliable scooper
i don't want to be a scooper though i
hate the term
and that's why i just try and report as
few things as possible unless i feel
that they're very very accurate
however there are people that do this
and they have big channels
and there's spider-man 3 gonna be at
ccxp
got everyone hyped up including me and i
watched the entire monster hunter panel
waiting for a big reveal
and felt like a bit of an idiot at the
end of it now what ccxp
actually did was that they announced
there was going to be a six-hour warner
media's panel
and didn't really put a schedule out
until about an hour before the event
thus over the weekend tons of people
were speculating about there being a cat
suit reveal
us seeing more of the snyder cut there
being a godzilla verse kong trailer
and a lot of hype built up around this
now this isn't really cc xp's fault
but the fact that they didn't post the
schedule until this point
well people are obviously going to
speculate and thus you know it's not
entirely on our shoulders or the people
reporting it
however as i've mentioned with the
spider-man 3 thing you know when i was
looking at this i just thought there's
no way that there's going to be a big
reveal here
the monster hunter panel had 800 people
watching it
and there was absolutely no reason that
a big studio like warner brothers would
want to drop
something massive to that that's short
of a crowd basically
they did say at the start of the warner
media panel that it was going to be like
dc fandom but it was basically a
highlight reel of dc
fandom without any of the highlights
thus we saw lots of trailers that we'd
seen before
learned very little and overall you know
it was a waste of time
especially if you're a comic book movie
enthusiast and have been following this
stuff from
august and kind of know all the ins and
outs of it
now like i said there was a schedule
posted beforehand
but it didn't really have the ins and
outs all the breakdowns of it
and thus it was very difficult to tell
whether this was going to be accurate or
not
even when i posted it the other day and
said look this is the complete schedule
i had people still saying well could
there not be a batman trailer there
could there not be a godzilla vs kong
one because it just wasn't well defined
enough and those
people's imaginations ran wild now
whoever edited
together the introduction for that panel
made one big mistake
and that is that they put a clip of
godzilla vs kong in it
right at the beginning so a lot of
people thought well this is definitely
gonna be at the event
and i'm gonna stay watching for the next
six hours maybe it wasn't a mistake
maybe they did it on purpose to keep
people engaged but
either way it led to a lot of angry
people i was pretty much watching the
stream for the six hours
and it was a constant flurry of godzilla
vs kung trailer now
and and little angry faces popping up
all the time
now that for six hours is absolutely
agonizing
and it just didn't make for a fun watch
at all however within the first 30
minutes i knew there wasn't gonna be
anything big at the event and i just
thought should i turn this off it just
looks like a repeat of stuff that we
already know
however cc xp did something very very
cruel
and they put a time slot in for nine
o'clock well not a secret panel
but it teased and said it's not the end
or something to that effect
therefore people like me you know i
think you know should i go to bed
it's it's getting near midnight and i'm
exhausted
and we thought we'll stay around and see
what this is
wasn't worth it it wasn't wasn't worth
it i must say
i think it was just people dancing to a
band and i can't even remember what song
it was it was that late but it sucked
so we kind of have this mismanagement on
their part of really defining what the
event is gonna be
and in doing so expectations were able
to run wild
personally i would have just listed
everything top to bottom
and therefore people can look at it
gauge what's gonna happen
and then be like right well you know i'm
not gonna be mad if there's no godzilla
vs kong trailer here because they
haven't teased it
but the fact that they did at the start
of the panel and also left some mystery
at the end of it
and made people like myself think well
maybe the scoopers are right this time
they would they would now i feel like
this video is very
very negative but unfortunately that's
the main feeling that i got from
watching it
whether it was down to me expecting too
much ccxp
not really outlining what was gonna
happen or just people running wild with
reports in order to make money
everything was a colossal disappointment
even jim lee popping in to say there's
no batman footage today but i'm gonna
wear a t-shirt and stand in front the
logo
it felt like a bit of a kick in the
teeth personally i just don't think that
warner brothers wanted to blow their
load at this event
especially when the audience was so
small they had the opportunity here to
either post
trailers online on youtube directly
collect
all of the monetization from that and
make lots and lots of money
or do a live stream for 800 people
make no money and you know they didn't
have to so they just showed footage that
they'd already
shown even mtv last night got a brand
new exclusive clip of wonder woman
and it's clear that you know whilst they
give some stuff to cc xp
they know where the bigger audience is
and thus marketed the brand new
crazy stuff to that now unfortunately
comic-con really seems to have
underwhelmed everyone this year and even
justice khan completely outshone the one
in the summer
it's difficult to really take anything
massive from this one
and it just feels like a bit of a
letdown i know a lot of it is down to
the pandemic and it's not the creator's
fault
but personally i think they should have
just postponed the event because
they didn't really have the lineup to
justify this runtime
it was also of course the delays that
went into it and when so many movies
have been pushed back you don't want to
announce and show clips for once
two years in the future so you're just
focusing on the ones that you've already
marketed
for the last 12 months even
announcements like the snyder cut
continuing in comics
just got overshadowed because
expectations had been set
so high that we were going to get a
godzilla verse kong trailer
and therefore that's all people focused
on and it completely let everyone down
so i was to blame you were to blame ccxp
was to blame
scubas were to blame i think the entire
time i just felt like john cena
during that suicide squad clip
completely let down
now if you enjoyed the video or if you
have a different perspective to me
and obviously i'd love to hear in the
comments section below so make sure you
drop them
if you want to see a breakdown of the
the best two seconds of the entire event
then we put together a video that goes
through the ins and outs of the godzilla
vs con clip
and points out all the things you missed
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set and all you have to do to be with
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and drop a comment below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of december
so make sure you get involved anyway
thanks for sticking around till the end
of the video i've been ball you being
the best i'll see you next time don't
cry don't cry please don't cry
uh